Một bà thằng sáng, phó chút thì cười đồng ăn đi ngà đi midu truy mai về đáp từ bố,
mắt cơ bàn sẽ không thà thư cho các cuộc tấn công bằng URV của quen nè.
Hỏi đây là hành động không thể chứng nhận,
tuyên bố đu dương ra sau gồng đầm phát mối tại Instagram,
nơi ngay khẳng định hai bên đã sảo quyết định một số bận đề thực tế.
Chứ đó, ngay ngủ một thằng sáng URV đã tính hành chính dịch URV của một lưỡng,
mang mặt sang mặt nghe.
Sự dụng ở một trong thế bị không người lấy tấn công sâu với lãnh thủng ai.
Rồi trước khi F cho biết hơn, bố mối mấy bài bị phá hủy hỏi thứ 2,
tại các cân cửa một mang E-CURSE, RISE M và Amir,
ngà sáng dạc một số sân bài bị tập kích, nhưng tuyên bố phần lớn của W đã bị chặt đứng,
không gây thương bàm.
Fíu quên là tuyên bố chính sịch là cái quả chuẩn bị dài hành.
Mấy một tiêu làm suy yếu năng lực tắc chiến chính lợi của ngà.
Chúng khi đó, giới phần tinh nhận định,
được thấy này có thể kiến ngà thay đổi cái tiếp cận quân sự trong thời gian tới.